يعتقد معظم الناس أن امتلاك ببغاء
هو نزهة في الحديقة ولكن الحقيقة هي
أنهم كائنات معقدة للغاية من
كل النواحي التي عاشوا فيها لفترة طويلة ويمكن أن تكون
صاخبة ويمكن أن تكون مدمرة
ولديهم احتياجات خاصة يتحدونك تقولها
كسر كالكلب بالنسبة لي ، يرجى من الناس
شرائهم أحيانًا لأسباب خاطئة
حيث يشترون على الفور وعندما تكون
هناك مشكلة
ينادونني ، اسمي جلين سيرينو وأنا أعمل
مع الطيور بشكل احترافي لمدة 20 عامًا كانت
مدينة نيويورك دائمًا  في
الفناء الخلفي لمنزلتي الخلفية ، كنت أعيش في طيور الببغاوات عندما
كنت طفلاً وكنت مفتونًا بكل ما
يتعلق بها ، فبدأت في النهاية
في البحث عن الببغاوات ، وقراءة
كل ما يمكنني التحدث
إليه مع أصحاب الطيور الآخرين ، وذهبت إلى اجتماعات نادي الطيور
، بل وحصلت على وظيفة.  في متجر الطيور
الذي فتح لي الكثير من الأبواب
على أساس يومي ، أقدم
مجموعة متنوعة من الخدمات التي أكون هناك كلما
احتاجوا إلي بشكل أساسي على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع كل يوم هو
شيء جديد كل يوم كتحدي
لكل طائر  لديه سلوك مختلف ،
فهم يشبهون الأشخاص الذين يحبونهم
ويكرهون ، ولديهم احتياجات خاصة في
طريقة بيئة إضاءة النظام الغذائي ، حيث
يمكن للأنواع الأكبر أن تعيش حياة الإنسان ،
وامتلاك طائر يشبه حرفيًا إنجاب
طفل يبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات لا يكبر أبدًا
إذا كنت  يمكن أن تتخيل أن مالكي الطيور
غالبًا ما يواجهون مشاكل تتعلق بالعدوانية ، مشاكل
صحية ،
مشاكل في وضع البيض ، تقليد
الأصوات التي تصبح
مستمرة إذا فهمت كيف
يفكر الطائر إذا فهمت ما يخبرك به الطائر
في الطريقة التي يتوسع بها التلاميذ
بالطريقة التي يهوون بها ذيولهم  يمكنك
معرفة ما يحاولون
إخبارك به مرة أخرى ، فأنا أتحدث لغتهم
ولا أعتقد أن هناك أي شخص آخر
يفعل ما أفعله حقًا ، وأعتقد أن
لدي دورًا فريدًا في عالم الطيور
أشعر أن هذا العمل  ما أفعله مفيد جدًا
بالنسبة لي ، فأنا أحب الطيور ، وأساعد
العملاء في حل المشكلات وعندما
يتصلون بي ويخبرونني أن كل
شيء رائع ، فأنا أساعدهم حقًا ،
يجعلني أشعر أنني حقًا  ملك
فرق في العالم وأنا أحب
النهاية السعيدة ولا شيء يجعلني أشعر
أفضل من معرفة أنني فعلت عملاً جيدًا
[موسيقى]